what is your sign
I'm a Leo see I don't know what any of
this means so you just asked it didn't
you so I'm I'm I know I just know I'm an
aquarius okay Leo's in Aquarius they get
along well we get along yeah we get
along what who don't you get along with
Scorpios what months are that like I
don't even know I don't I don't pay
attention to scriptbooks but when you
say your Scorpio it's like is Drake a
Scorpio no Drake's a Libra
nocturnal I think he'll put it out
yeah I think he is Scorpio any Scorpios
in here
nope okay that's good
so if you are like let's say you go out
on a date with a guy and you find out
he's a Scorpio is that a rap
yeah we probably didn't even get along
during the day what if you did get along
and like everything was going great and
then he was like I was born on October
24th and then you're like
yeah they're just full of [__] so
probably really yeah they're sneaky like
it probably went so great and I probably
think the world is like peaches and
creams with them but I just know deep
down they're full of [__] really yeah I
you know I didn't know that this existed
like you would like discriminate against
someone you liked because of their I
mean I mean they can't choose that yeah
it depends um
I guess it depends on it depends on how
good it was like how good the date was
what if I might consider okay okay okay
yeah that's fair uh well listen man uh
shout out to all the Scorpios out there
just know she will discriminate against
you yeah and very bad and if you work at
Amazon you're [__]
you work at Amazon and be a Scorpio
that's the double whammy I might just
walk past you uh what what do you do in
your free time right now you've like
streaming TV are you uh working out are
you playing video games what do you do
when you're on like when you're not
recording or running around the country
pushing your music
um I'm getting into like I love to cook
so I'm trying to start my own little
like cooking
I don't know is it like the reels and
the shows and stuff yeah I'm trying to
you know start doing that I have a dog
we just be at the house
my t-shirt too oh like a little a little
puppy his name is Chase Chase yeah like
that uh what do you cook like what's
your go-to dish
uh I so it's so funny because I put in a
song uh pasta Lobster but it's actually
like my go-to dish now like so the
lobster pasta is what your go-to is yeah
you gotta try it it's so good can you
cook up like any special sort of ramen
noodles like if you were to make a pack
of noodles yeah and you put like the egg
and the shrimp
and like the green onions and stuff it's
like it's Ramen
Chicken in there some people will put
like uh just hot sauce and like melted
cheese and cheese yeah you never put
cheese in your noodles
y'all put cheese in y'all noodles
I do oh no
you just put like uh so look the you
know is it like a single cheese slice it
could be
friend I don't like that and then look
and then you just stir it and then it
melts into the noodles
I don't like that food then you get
Tapatio hot sauce then some soy sauce
it's soy sauce too yeah and then you put
the beef pack in
and and a little bit of butter
I swear to God I swear to God it's good
I swear that sounds horrible
it definitely sounds like diarrhea
because our screaming I don't
it sounds like prison
it sounds like spread it is funny
because like I didn't know
subconsciously as a kid I was just
making spread the whole time until I
started to see these rappers put
together their spreads and I was like I
was eating that when I was a kid
shout out to my parents let me eat like
a [__] convict when I was 11. I'm
still trying to figure out what a spread
is so when you're in jail they'll
they'll take like because you know in
jail there's like limited stuff you can
get your hands on right so they'll take
like noodles they'll take like sardines
or tuna they'll just put a bunch of [__]
together and then they'll mash it
together
right and then they'll cook it and then
it's like a they call it a spread I went
to jail for four days why
because I didn't show them to court and
it was on Memorial Day weekend
so so everybody was on vacation yeah
what was that like and they it was like
a it was actually in Douglasville
Georgia and so like they had everybody
like I just had a failure to appear for
speeding nothing crazy nothing crazy but
I was in there with women that was about
to do 15 years right so it was not fun
I've been to jail twice it's not fun
either yeah no let me ask you this when
you went to jail
did you notice anybody using the roll of
toilet paper as a pillow in the holding
cell no
I don't think I
think I don't think I talked to anybody
I just literally I didn't eat yeah
because you don't want to [__] in front
of everybody no I just that looks
disgusting no I didn't eat either
they give you like a bag of peanut
butter no they didn't they didn't give
me none of that they gave me were you in
a holding cell with a bunch of random
people yeah well it was just one other
person so I was in a holy cell with like
20 other dudes yeah
and I was like I am not [__] in here
so they gave you food I was like I need
nothing I took a roll of toilet paper
used it as a pillow in the corner and
just waited
it was terrible I don't like I don't
understand like when people go to jail
and they get out and then they go back
yeah it doesn't make sense yeah why did
it happen to you twice why why did you
go to jail the first time oh the first
time I went to jail was because I uh I
gave false information to a police
officer oh
and the second time I went to jail was
because uh the case is still open so we
won't talk about it okay okay okay
well cool but yeah it wasn't anything
crazy but uh yeah jail sucks